l'état français a été complice de
génocide en 1994
et si ce rapport ne le dit pas nous
attendons de l'exécutif une prise de
parole forte pour que cette complicité
soit reconnue c'est le seul moyen pour
qu'il y ait ensuite un contrôle
démocratique qui se mit en place sur nos
institutions sur les opérations
extérieures
le risque sinon c'est que ce type
d'actions soit répétée et qu'elle se
répéter au nom du peuple français
ça change beaucoup parce que il ya
normalement négationnisme notamment en
france je fais de la présence de
génocidaires et de leur famille sur le
territoire
donc le fait que les politiques prennent
enfin en compte ces mots la force ça ne
peut être qu'une bonne chose parce que
ça permet aussi un petit pot de faire
reculer le sentiment d'impunité
ces mots là c'est très bien mais il ya
des personnes à juger en france il ya
des personnes dont il faut regarder
quelles furent leurs actes leurs mots
leurs écrits lors du génocide et ça va
plus être en fait les actes notre
préoccupation au jour le jour